welcome back everyone this is part nine
in our series on contextual
representation for part nine we're going
to switch gears a little bit and talk
about distillation the name of the game
here is going to be efficiency we are
seeking models that are smaller and
therefore more efficient to use
especially at inference time but
nonetheless very performant and
distillation is a set of techniques for
achieving that
on the first day of the course I had
this slide that tracked model size over
time for our large language models and
you saw it going up and up and up all
the way to Palm at like 4 540 billion
parameters and then I offered a hopeful
perspective that models would start
getting smaller and one perspective on
why models might get smaller is that we
can distill the essence of these really
large models down into the small ones
and therefore get models that are more
efficient when deployed
the name of the game for distillation is
that we have a teacher model that is
presumably very good but also very large
and therefore very expensive to use and
the goal is to train a student model
that has similar input output Behavior
to the teacher
uh but is nonetheless much more
efficient to use
and we can do that in very lightweight
ways that simply depend on having the
student mimic the teacher in terms of
its basic input output Behavior
but we can also think about going deeper
and having it be the case that we train
the student to have internal
representations that are similar in some
sense to those of the teacher to gain an
even deeper distillation of that teacher
so in that context let's review some
distillation objectives and what I've
done here is list them out from least to
most heavy duty and of course you'll
commonly see that people take weighted
averages of different elements of this
list
for item zero on the list I just
mentioned that you will probably distill
your student by in part training it on
gold data for the task if you have it
available and can make use of it and so
we're talking essentially about
supplementing that core training with
additional components of the the
objective
so the first distillation objective and
the most lightweight one is that we
simply train the student to produce the
same output as the teacher this is very
lightweight because at distillation time
we actually don't require any direct
access to the teacher we simply run the
teacher on all our available training
data it produces labels and then we
train the student on those labels
it's a bit mysterious why that is useful
I think the guiding Insight here is that
there might be aspects of your training
data that are noisy or just very
difficult to learn
so the teacher acts as a kind of
regularizer and the student benefits
from seeing the teacher's output even if
it contains some mistakes because that
ultimately helps with generalization
going one layer deeper we could train
the student to have similar output
Behavior as the teacher at the level of
the full Vector of output scores this is
in fact the centerpiece of one of the
most famous distillation papers Hinton
at all 2015. it's a little bit more
heavy duty than just the output labels
because we do require those entire score
vectors but it's still a kind of purely
behavioral distillation objective
going one layer deeper in the famous
distilbert paper sawn at all 2019 in
addition to having components that are
like one and two their distillation
objective also has a cosine loss
component here what we're trying to do
is have the teacher and student output
states in the Transformer sense be very
similar to each other this requires much
more access to the teacher at
distillation time because we need to do
forward inference on the teacher for
each example that we train the student
on to get those output States and then
apply the cosine loss and update the
student
you could also think about tying other
teacher and student States other hidden
States and maybe most prominently the
embedding layers for the teacher and
student model again with an intuition
that the models will be more alike in
the student therefore more powerful if
it's internal representations mimic
those of the teacher
and then maybe even more heavy duty this
is work that I was involved with We Now
train the student to mimic the
counterfactual behavior of the teacher
under interventions that is instances in
which we actually change the internal
state of the teacher and do the same
kind of corresponding thing to the
student and ensure that the two have
matching input output behavior and
that's a kind of more thorough
exploration of the input output Behavior
putting the model into counterfactual
states with the hope that it will lead
the models to have very similar causal
internal structure
four three four and five this is very
heavy duty in the sense that we do
require full access to the teacher at
distillation time but in all of these
cases I'm presuming that the teacher is
a frozen artifact and all you have to do
is forward inference
there's another dimension to these
distillation objectives that is worth
thinking about and again these can can
be combined with each other and with the
different modes that I just described
in standard distillation the teacher is
Frozen as I said before and only the
student parameters are updated
we could also think about multi-teacher
distillation in this case we have
multiple teachers maybe with different
capabilities and we simultaneously try
to distill them all down into a single
student that can presumably perform
multiple tasks coming from those
teachers
code distillation is really
interestingly different to think about
in this case the student and the teacher
are trained jointly this is sometimes
also called online distillation and so
this is very heavy duty in the sense
that you're training both of these
artifacts simultaneously and it's kind
of hard to think about
self-distillation is even harder to
think about in this case the
distillation objective includes terms
that seek to make some model components
align with others from the same model
[Music]
in terms of performance this is kind of
the name of the game as I said before we
are seeking artifacts that are more
efficient but nonetheless still
performant and so I thought I would wrap
up this short screencast by just
summarizing what we know for the
specific case of natural language
understanding focused on glue
based on the evidence I think it's fair
to say that we can distill Bert models
down into much smaller models that are
still highly performant a lot of This
research has used the glue Benchmark to
kind of track this and it's all
converging on the same Insight in the
famous distilbert paper they took Bert
base and distilled it down into six
layers with 97 percent of the glue
performance retained Sun at all did
something similar they tried Bert based
on into three layer and six layer and
also saw that they could main maintain
outstanding performance on glue
similarly jow at all 2020 distilled burp
Basin to four layers and again saw very
strong results on glue
this set of results here is noteworthy
because it's converging on the same
lesson we can make Burke much smaller by
distilling down into a much smaller
student that still does well on
benchmarks Like Glue and so that should
be inspiring in terms of thinking about
distillation as a powerful tool in your
toolkit for taking very large and maybe
expensive teachers and turning them into
things that might have more practical
utility out in the world